[موسيقى
] الهندسة المعمارية التي يمكنك رؤيتها هنا هي في
الواقع مزيج من
نمط الأرابيسك ونمط الأسانوها الياباني
، المصممة مسوكو ناجاياما عندما
رأت لأول مرة الأرابيسك الذي رأت فيه بعض
التشابه مع نمط أساناها الياباني
بالطبع لدينا علاقة طويلة
مع الحرير  الطريق أيضًا ، لذا
أرادت مزج هذه الأفكار معًا
، وهكذا توصلنا إلى
التقاء الثقافتين مع بعضهما البعض ، وهذا في
الواقع هو المفهوم الكامل
لجناحنا ، وهو مستوحى من الفطر ، ثم فكرنا في نمط الصلوها لدينا.
الطريقة التي بها الماء في
المقدمة وتعطي نسيمًا طبيعيًا
بداخلها يتم تمثيلها أيضًا في
جناحنا أيضًا ، ولهذا السبب لدينا
واجهة بحرية جميلة أمام
جناح ولأننا لم نغطي واجهتنا ،
فهي في الهواء الطلق لذا فهي  يجلب
الهواء الطبيعي إلى الداخل وهذا ما
تعلمناه أيضًا من
المسجرية وأيضًا من ثقافة اليابان ومرة أخرى نم
جها معًا ير
ز جناحنا إلى  تلتقي أفكار إعادة الأفكار
بحيث
تلتقي أفكارها وثقافاتها ببعضها
البعض ويمكننا أن نصنع أشياء مختلفة إذا
مزجنا الأفكار معًا ،
لذا فإن الطريقة التي نصمم بها فافصة لدينا
ترمز إلى الطريقة التي نحن بها في اليابان
والطريقة التي نريد أن نجعلها أفضل
المستقبل بأفكارك أيضًا
جناح المعجبين عبارة عن جولة إرشادية مدتها ساعة واحدة
ولكن لدينا ستة مشاهد مختلفة في جناحنا ،
لذا في أول مشهد
سيبدأ الزائرون بمقابلة
اليابان ، فكيف
التقى الإله والإلهة وكيف تم إنشاء بلدنا
ثم يليه المشهد الثاني
الذي نعود فيه إلى التاريخ
والثقافات التي لدينا
والمشهد الثالث هو موضوع ابتكارات
لذا السيد تاتيا تاناكا هو فنان واحد
يتخيل القيام بكل الإبداع في
c3 ونتحدث عن ابتكاراتنا مثل
hayabusa  2
نموذج مهمة العودة
والمشهد 4 من المهم جدًا أن
نركز مرة أخرى على القضايا العالمية التي
نريد معالجة القضايا العالمية
معًا
والتي في مشهد الذروة كيف
نقول هذا
هل نحتفظ باهتمامك سرًا في
المكان الذي زرته في جناحنا ،
على سبيل المثال إذا أظهرت
مساحة فضاء مثيرة للاهتمام أو إذا أظهرت
اهتمامًا بالغابة ،
فستظهر الصورة الرمزية الصغيرة الجديدة
، وهذا يشبه دون أن تفكر في
ما أنت مهتم به  لذلك يبدو الأمر كما لو
كنت تجد نفسك
الجديدة وأيضًا في النهاية نعطي ضبابًا جيدًا
أن العالم بلا
حدود وفي النهاية ستذهب إلى
2025 osaka kansai japan الذي
نستضيف المعرض القادم مع  فكرة
[موسيقى]